Hallo, Chat?
Chatke?
Vodafone hat einfach meinen Router neu gestartet.
Meinen Router.
Einfach so, einfach so Reboot.
Zwischen mitten am Tag hat sich das Ding restartet.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob die es restartet haben oder ob einfach nur der Link zu denen abgekackt ist.
Aber es war kaputt.
Guck, wie ihr hier seht.
Da, hier, guck.
Timeout, Timeout, Timeout.
Und dann irgendwann ging es wieder.
Nice.
Exzellent.
So, kurz noch mal Fenster ein bisschen wieder offen machen.
Ihr habt übrigens meinen Fail gar nicht mehr gesehen mit Power Top, oder?
Wollte.
Ich wollte Power Top schreiben.
Und habe aus Versehen Power Off gemacht.
Und dann habe ich mich gewundert, warum der Chat jetzt nicht gleich irgendwie einen blöden Spruch bringt.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, ah, das Internet ist weg.
Ja, Reboot ist Recommended.
So, dann, wenn der Reboot Recommended ist, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir das doch mal, oder?
Reboot.
die Tastatur umstecken.
Also Leute, ich denke,
ich bin so bis 18 Uhr oder so bin ich da.
Das reicht mir dann auch
auf Monitor gucken.
Übrigens, Chat,
also wie gesagt, wir machen heute jetzt nichts Spannendes
oder so. Bin ich geistig
heute so nicht in der Lage.
Meine Festplatte ist heute angekommen.
Eigentlich
habe ich ja gesagt, sobald die Festplatte
ankommt, also die externe
Festplatte, machen wir
einen Shocking, Shocking,
wird geschuckt, einen Shocking-Stream.
Aber ich sehe mich heute
nicht in der Lage, einen ordentlichen
Shocking-Stream zu machen.
26 Terabyte.
Was wir theoretisch machen können,
das machen wir dann auch im nächsten Stream,
Ich wollte sagen, wir könnten theoretisch schon gucken, ob das eine SMR oder CMR Platte ist.
Aber das können wir uns auch einfach schenken und machen das dann das nächste Mal.
Zumindest ist das preislich gar nicht so schlecht gewesen.
Ja, preislich gar nicht so schlecht.
499 Euro.
Ja, Festplatte ist da.
Festplatte kam heute an.
Angeblich sollte die Festplatte erst nächste Woche kommen.
Aber die kam heute schon.
Ja, wird geschuckt.
Aber wie gesagt, heute nicht.
So, ich habe mir ja dieses Ding bestellt.
Guckt mal.
sie geht desktop expansion dieses teil hier mal gucken was es auf geiz alter
mal gucken was es auf geiz als kostet 26 leute kann das sein dass ich verkackt
hat mit 499 euro nicht auf lager habe ich vielleicht habe ich aber ich
vielleicht voll verkackt kann das sein und sie fielen zu viel dafür ausgegeben
26 499 das günstigste was es aktuell gibt ja die habe ich gekauft
Mein Plan ist jetzt, ich teste jetzt mal am NAS, also nicht jetzt, jetzt, sondern nächsten
Stream, wenn wir das machen, wieder fit bin, teste ich erstmal, ob das SMR oder CMR Platten
sind, so ein paar Benchmarks, die man machen kann, wo man das halbwegs brauchbar ableiten
kann, soweit ich das gelesen habe.
Was übrigens ein bisschen Fail ist, guck mal hier, Anschlüsse, Mikro, Mikro, Mikro B ist das auch noch.
Das ist nicht Mikro USB, das ist dieser hässliche, dieser komische, ja der da ist das.
What the fuck?
Warum, warum gibt es irgendeinen Hersteller auf der Welt, der diesen dämlichen Stecker verwendet?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Der dümmste Stecker aller Zeiten.
Ich hoffe, da sind Kabel dabei, weil so einen Stecker habe ich gar nicht da.
Moin.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Habt ihr so einen Stecker schon mal gesehen, Chat?
Oder hattet ihr mal ein Gerät mit so einem Stecker?
Also ich kann mich jetzt nicht...
Also ich weiß, dass es den gibt.
Aber ich...
Ich kann mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht daran erinnern, so einen gehabt zu haben.
Warum, warum,
Chat, warum macht man so einen Stecker
anstatt diesen normalen hier?
Gerätestecker da.
Weil genug Platz ist an dem Ding ja.
So, da hat man diesen fetten alten Stecker.
Alter, da ist er komplett sinnlos.
Nur bei externen, ja, ist ja auch eine externe Platte.
Ah, das Teil hier.
Jetzt werden wir dann schucken.
Nicht in Schleim, sondern geschuckt.
Oder geschackt, wie man das eigentlich korrekt ausspricht.
Joa
Was macht eigentlich der Knopf da oben
Okay braucht keiner
Es ist genauso wie dieses komische
Hier unten bei Windows was auch kass aufverwendet
Ich gehe davon aus
Dass das
dass das vor USB-C war.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn die jetzt noch neue Geräte rausbringen,
mit 26T und so, die sind auf jeden Fall neuer als USB-C.
Hätte man ja mal ein USB-C-Update bringen können,
anstatt so Micro-USB 3.0 und Micro-B.
Korrekterweise dürften die ja auch nicht USB 3.0 schreiben,
sondern USB 3.2 Gen 1x1 oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaube, das war sogar das Korrekte, oder?
Für USB 3.0.
USB 3.2 Gen 1x1 oder so.
Niemand blickt bei den USB-Namen durch.
Keiner blickt da mehr durch.
Ich behaupte sogar mal, dass die Leute, die in diesem USB-Gremium sitzen, selbst nicht mehr durchblicken.
Erstaunliche Parallelen zum C++ Gremium
Finde ich auch
C++ Gremium
Vielleicht gibt es da auch Überscheidungen
Lass uns mal kurz die KI fragen
Gibt es
Gibt es Personen
Die
Im USB Gremium
Sitzen
Forum heißt das
Sitzen und
gleichzeitig im
C++ Gremium.
Das fragen wir jetzt mal mehrere AIs,
weil ChatGPT richtig dumm ist.
Ja, das ist möglich und kommt auch vor.
Okay,
ChatGPT schwallt wieder
und hat eigentlich gar keinen Plan.
Ja, es gibt vermutlich mehrere Personen, die sowohl im USB-Standardisierungskontext als
auch im C++-Komitee aktiv sind.
Ja, siehste?
Siehste?
Das erklärt es doch schon mal ein bisschen, oder?
Findet ihr nicht?
Es gibt keine prominente Einzelperson.
Aber Google AI meint es wäre nicht so.
Tja.
Gab es nicht mal Update des Namensschemas bei USB, wo nach dem alten Schema und neuem Schema zwei unterschiedliche Standards den gleichen Namen hatten?
Jaja, das machen die permanent.
Die benennen rückwirkend alte Sachen um.
Bei USB 3.2 haben sie es so gemacht, dass USB 3.0 und USB 3.1 hießen dann auf einmal auch 3.2, aber Gen 1, Gen 2 und Gen 2x2 und sowas.
Nicht Gen 3.
Oder 3x1, ach keine Ahnung mehr.
Aber das ist laufend bei denen. Proxmox, nice.
Irgendwas wollte ich vorher noch auf meiner Proxmox-Kiste machen, als der Stream abgekackt ist.
und sage, ach Chat, wir können doch gerade mal gucken,
ob...
Jetzt habe ich es vergessen.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Auf jeden Fall nichts
sonderlich
ähm
gehirnintensives heute.
Ich habe heute
im Bett,
also ich habe heute ja
Mittag mit Nase laufen,
habe ich ein bisschen im Bett YouTube geguckt
durch ein echt cooles Video.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt aber nicht an.
Das nur, weil das ist
41 Minuten C-Sharp-Technik-Talk.
Aber nur für einen,
den das interessiert. Ich fand, das hier war ein echt gutes Video.
Übrigens, jetzt wird es gleich grausam,
weil wir haben noch keine
richtige YouTube-Historie hier im Browser.
Das kommt nur Mist hier.
One trillion
Pixel Maze hieß das.
Hier, das ist ein Konferenzvortrag,
den habe ich heute Mittag im Bett geguckt.
Der ist echt gut beschrieben,
was er da für Optimierungen gemacht hat
in seinem
Labyrinth-Lös-
Programm.
Also wer sich Sharp programmiert,
sich für die Sharp-Optimierung interessiert,
kann sich das hier mal angucken.
Ich muss YouTube zumachen,
sonst kriege ich Anfälle.
Chat, soll ich euch mal sagen
ups
was ich echt gerne programmieren würde irgendwann mal
aber
was ich garantiert nicht anfange
also es gibt so eine Sache, die würde ich echt gerne programmieren
aber die fange ich nicht an
weil ich weiß, dass es alleine eh nicht zu schaffen ist
beziehungsweise
ich mich kenne und
und ich eh nicht lange noch dabei bleibe.
Ich würde gerne ein eigenes Monitoring-System programmieren, irgendwann mal.
So best of Nagios Zabbix Prometheus.
Mit knapp 30 Jahren, naja, nicht ganz, 25 Jahren,
dann wahrscheinlich Admin-Erfahrung, was man da so braucht und nicht braucht.
aber das ist alleine eh nicht zu stemmen und ich habe kein Team, das das macht.
Also und ich glaube da gibt es auch nicht so einen Riesenmarkt dafür.
Also ich würde es aber auch nicht machen, weil ich es verkaufen will, sondern weil Serverüberwachung
ist so was, da finde ich es gibt, es gibt eigentlich nur weniger beschissene Systeme.
Es gibt eigentlich kaum...
Nee, LibreNMS. LibreNMS ist ganz nice
für so Sachen wie Router und Switches.
Aber du willst damit garantiert
keine Linux-Server überwachen
oder gar Metriken einsammeln und sowas.
Es hat alles so ein bisschen seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ja, Zabbix hat seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Prometheus oder
victoria mit tricks best of dingen auch alles seine daseinsberechtigung ja wohin die prometo
ist es halt richtig gut zahlen zu speichern im endeffekt mit ricken also mit ricken sind ja
zahlen so aber monitor also man kann mit zahlen viel repräsentieren ja portabell down kannst du
repräsentieren und null oder eins oder was auch immer aber so sachen wie letzter eingeloggt der
user das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so geil als zahl zu repräsentieren ja und das kann man
natürlich auch tricksen in prometheus ein bisschen du kannst dann sagen last login time und was label
für den user aber da sieht man schon so ganz gut dafür gedacht dass jetzt auch nicht also klassische
monitor gesachen so was wie nagios und zabbix hat schon seinen sinn genauso wie prometheus
oder ein bisschen neuere
Geschichten, wie diese
ganzen, was jetzt voll im Trend ist, diese ganzen
Observability-Plattformen, wo dann noch
Traces, Logs, Metriken
gesammelt werden, wo du dann gucken kannst, was
ist hier zu diesem Zeitraum, in diesem Zeitraum
aufgedreht und sowas. Schon alles cool.
Aber irgendwie finde ich
eine Plattform schlechter als die andere.
Also für mich
persönlich, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
von so
All-in-One-Monitoring-Systemen finde ich
nach wie vor Zabbix.
nice
Das ding ist halt zabbix es hat so abartige konfiguration
Ob andere sachen die ich nicht gut finde am besten wäre in den hybrids so aus prometheus und zabbix
Und halt was was out of the box schon sehr viel mitbringt
und wo du sowohl über das Webinterface konfigurieren kannst,
als auch über irgendeine API-Sache.
Also ich habe da schon eine recht umfangreiche Vorstellung,
wie so das für mich optimale Monitoring-System aussehen könnte.
Das ist was, das würde ich unglaublich gerne machen,
aber dafür brauchst du ein Team von Leuten.
Und wenn man das natürlich nicht als Produkt,
Also erstens glaube ich kann man das nicht als Produkt gescheit verkaufen heutzutage,
gibt es einfach zu viel etabliertes schon und so was wahnbrechendes, dass da jemand
umsteigt gibt es im Monitoringbereich jetzt auch nicht.
Außerdem will ich ja überhaupt kein Geld damit verdienen, ich will einfach ein Monitoring-System
bauen, was so meinen Vorstellungen als aus 25 Jahren Linux-Administration entspricht,
wie es mir gefällt aber macht natürlich keiner mit und alleine kriegt man das nicht hin zumal
da auch viel planung noch mit dran hängt so erstmal so das was da mit dem kopf rum schwirrt
dann irgendwas konkretes draus zu wollen aber das ist was ich unglaublich gerne machen würde
aber kann ich halt vergessen so ich hätte ein hessens vorzeige stellen oder da rege ich mich
mich doch bestimmt wieder auf wenn ich das video gucken muss ich zwischendurch
zum husten immer mal ein bisschen muten nicht wundern
welches video welches welches video ist
dass er
Ach, das ist FRM 1.
Was mich viel mehr interessiert ist...
Ach, die Webseite ist sogar mittlerweile down.
Sehr schön.
Oh, das bei mir ist halt wieder im Arsch.
Das Ding klappt so wenig,
dass sogar die Webseite
Webseite schon im Arsch ist mittlerweile.
Ja, es gibt einen nordrheinischen,
äh, nicht rheinischen, mainischen und einen südmainischen.
Ja, FHM7, da gibt's irgendwie
zwei. Die kommen auch nicht voran. Die sind jetzt
irgendwie bei der dritten Machbarkeitsstudie, Alter.
Das fuckt mich in Deutschland echt ab.
Dieses unsägliche, ewig geplane
und nix kommt bei raus.
Und wenn man dann anfängt,
dann siedelt dort die
seltene Wildgrille oder so und dann
kann man das nicht weiterbauen.
Ja.
Chat, bei mir hat gerade unten im Flur die Tür komische Geräusche gemacht.
Ich muss mal kurz auf meine Überwachungskameras gucken, was da los ist.
Äh, nix.
Nix.
Minusumsteiger hier seit drei Monaten.
Wie geht's so? Ich bin krank.
Aber ansonsten geht's ganz gut.
Also ich hatte mir das tatsächlich schon mal angeguckt.
Libre NMS und Open NMS.
und das hat
einen guten Eindruck gemacht für so Sachen wie
Switche und sowas
also alles was du per SNMP
überwachen kannst, aber für Serverüberwachung
der Agent den es dafür gab
war auch irgendwie
hat einen sehr halbherzigen Eindruck auf mich gemacht
also das hat
und auch die Grafen waren
RRD oder wie das hieß so aus dem letzten Jahrtausend
Nextcloud Videos gucken wir morgen, falls ich morgen früh online komme.
Hast du ein Haustier?
Ne.
Aber das Coole ist,
seit gestern
kriege ich wohl regelmäßig Besuch.
Die stand gestern einfach bei mir vor der Tür.
Vor der Eingangstür.
Habe ich die Tür aufgemacht?
Oder ist die direkt reingeflitzt?
Und hat sich hier das Haus angeguckt und hat sich dann in die Vorratskammer gelegt und hat angefangen zu brummen.
Aber nach einer halben Stunde oder 45 Minuten oder so ist sie dann wieder heim.
Natürlich hat sie auch ein bisschen was gekriegt von mir.
wahrscheinlich kommt die deshalb jetzt öfters
die hat mich die hat mich wild markiert die hat die ganze zeit an mir umgeschleimt
ja und heute und heute war es wieder da guckt
Du hast ja auch Proxmox als Host-System und nimmst OMV als NAS.
Ja, Moment mal.
Es war ein Test. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wirklich so mache dann, unterm Strich.
ja wir probieren dann in also nächsten stream wird die festplatte geschuckt und dann müssen
wir noch mal ausprobieren wie die samba und nass performance in einem lxt container ist und ob ich
wirklich nur für zwei shares in den oms betreiben will aber das letzte mal so gemacht ja du hast ja
auch proxens system und nimmst um falls nass wo du den zfs ordner an oms durchreicht ja genau so ist
das so ist es wie hast du im vorinstallierten einer form plus docker container oder geht das
direkt als lxc container weder weder noch es gibt ein fertiges iso von media wollt es installiert
so in der form und fertig das hat mit docker nichts zu tun und als lxc container geht das
nicht weil die sagen halt sie wollen wenn platten dann direkten zugriff auf die platten ja schade
dass es da keine LXC-Variante gibt für ohne Plattenmanagement, wenn man so machen will wie ich.
Aber ich so, nee, nee, einfach VM und dann...
Und dann...
OMV installieren.
Guck hier.
Das prüfst du dann mit einem Pfeiltransfer.
Ja gut, das ist ja letztendlich auch das, was ich machen will.
Wir machen dann IPerf und wir machen dann Samba File Transfer und gucken wo es schneller ist.
Guck hier, da ist die OMV Kiste.
Und da ist nix mit Docker oder sonst was.
Ja, aber hast du richtig verstanden.
Was trinken?
Flüssigkeitszufuhr ist wichtig, wenn man erkältet ist.
Muss ich gleich noch einen zweiten Tee holen.
Ja, aber richtig.
Max, hast du es im Discord gelesen?
Ich habe gesehen, der RF-Programmer hat es dir ja schon geschrieben.
Das habe ich in einem der letzten Streams auch...
Also das stimmt, was er erzählt hat.
Also falls du Nass brauchst oder falls du irgendwie Storage brauchst
für das Wupplos-Archiv oder so auch immer,
dann sagt bescheid als ukraine 5800 plus haben aber das ist halt der nachteil
ohne platten und ramm
das heißt du musst dann erst noch niere und leber verkaufen dass du das auch
bestücken kannst
Ich würde es dir normalerweise sogar mit dem RAM geben, mit dem es ausgeliefert wurde.
Also mit 8 GB RAM wurde es ausgeliefert.
Aber mein Problem ist, ich habe von meinem Mini-PC die 32 GB RAM rausgemacht und in das NAS eingebaut.
Und die 8 GB RAM vom NAS in den Mini-PC.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt wieder zurückbaue, dann geht eine von den zwei Kisten nicht.
Oder ich müsste das RAM splitten. 16 da, 16 da.
auch noch eine möglichkeit hätte schon just dafür dann kann man discos das kopf schreiben
als falls ich wieder planlos bin weil ich meinte mein kopf ist eh messer pp jetzt auch noch mit
erkältung dann schreibt es einfach wenn ich ganz fertig vercheckt ich schreibe es einfach noch
haben extrem aber ich schicke dir das da ist es gut investiert hast du ja das haben wir so
im stream schon mal ausprobiert sunshine das ist ein nvidia ein nvidia game stream implementierung
das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice das habe ich ausprobiert um das hier mehr oder weniger zu
bauen was jetzt mit einer capture card gebaut habe ich wollte nämlich den mini pc also sprich
sprich die kiste auf der ich gerade bin
wollte ich quasi auf dem zweiten Windows Desktop verwenden, so wie ich es jetzt hier mache.
Und das halt mit Sunshine als Streaming.
Das hat auch, was Latency angeht und sowas, echt gut funktioniert.
Das war wirklich gut.
Das hatte aber Probleme mit Copy-Paste und Sound.
Und noch ein paar andere kleine Schönheitsfehler,
sodass ich im Endeffekt gesagt habe, na so 100% gut verwendbar ist das nicht
so und jetzt finde ich
und
jetzt finde ich, habe ich ein gutes Setup
guckt hier, jetzt habe ich, ich versuche es nochmal kurz zu erklären
also ich habe hier, machen wir das mal auf
Display, ich habe hier ein Mini-PC, das ist das was ihr hier gerade seht
Mini-PC, 240 Hertz
Full-HD-Bildschirm dran.
Also nicht direkt dran.
Und ich habe den Mini-PC-Output
auf meinem zweiten Windows-Desktop.
Ist super verwirrend, ich weiß.
Aber das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich habe zwei Windows-Desktops.
Hier, Desktop 1, Desktop 2.
Kann man hin und her schalten dazwischen.
Wenn ich hin und her schalte,
dazwischen ist das quasi,
wie ich es gerade gezeigt habe,
einfach nur über Shortcut.
So, und was ich jetzt gemacht habe,
ist folgendes.
Auf dem zweiten Desktop, wo ich jetzt hier auf dem Mini-Linux-PC bin, mit 240 Hertz, funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Das hier, das seht ihr jetzt ja auch gerade, das hier ist eigentlich ein OBS.
Das ist ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Jetzt, was ich auf dem zweiten Desktop habe.
Und ich habe eine Elgato 4K Capture Card oder 4K, wie heißt das Ding, Elgato 4K Pro, glaube ich.
Die kann halt 1080p 240 Hertz capturen.
und das habe ich hier im
OBS eingestellt, seht ihr, guckt hier
OBS 240 Hertz
und das OBS ist jetzt
nicht für Stream, das ist wirklich nur einfach zum
Fullscreen anzeigen auf dem zweiten
Display
so und was ich dann gemacht habe ist, ich habe Deskflow
installiert
Deskflow
ist ein
Tastatur und Maus Sharing Tool
das habe ich unter Windows und unter
Linux installiert. Guck hier, da läuft's.
Deskflow auf Windows, Deskflow auf Linux.
Und dann habe ich mir ein Maus-Makro,
äh, kein Maus-Makro,
ein
Tastatur-Makro
definiert. Hier Switch 1, Switch 2.
Und das Makro
macht folgendes.
Ich muss das andere zeigen.
Äh, hallo?
Warum sackt
die Logitech-Software so?
Und was das macht ist, das drückt linke Windows-Taste und Control und den Pfeil nach rechts.
Das macht, dass es auf den zweiten Desktop switcht.
Und dann drückt es Alt-A.
Alt-A ist ein Shortcut, den habe ich in Deskflow definiert und bedeutet, switche zum zweiten Rechner.
Und der zweite Rechner ist halt der hier neben dran.
Was in Wirklichkeit passiert, wenn ich hier zwischen Windows und Linux wechsle, ist im Prinzip ein Makro, was vom ersten Windows Desktop auf den zweiten Windows Desktop switcht, auf dem OBS im Fullscreen läuft und dann per Deskflow die Vm an meine Linux Kiste schert.
Äh, die Maus an meine Linux Kiste schert.
ich weiß nicht was kvm
Aten ist
aber es ist ähnlich wie eine
Software KVM
und das läuft halt
nahezu, ich will nicht sagen
100%ig latency free
aber es ist nahezu latency free
und ihr wisst wie sehr mich das abfuckt
wir können übrigens mal einen latency test machen
wenn ihr wollt
also wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal hier hin
machen wir mal einen latency test
ich weiß
rfprogrammer, das hat er auch noch hier geschrieben
gehen wir mal
human benchmark
meine reaktionszeiten werden richtig
mies sein
weil mit
erkältung und gedöns
also mal 150
ich bin ein alter sack
aber ich hab bis vor kurzer zeit noch 150
millisekunden reaktionszeit
hier hab ich live bewiesen im stream
Also, mal gucken, wie das jetzt ist.
Nicht schlecht, hä?
Nicht schlecht.
Chat.
Müsst ihr zugeben.
Nicht schlecht.
Na gut, das war nicht so gut.
Da sind keine Boomer Reaction. 158 ist ziemlich gut.
Das ist ziemlich nice.
Ich wette mit euch, das ist wahrscheinlich eine bessere Reaktionsteil, als die meisten von euch haben.
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Also der Durchschnittswert hier ist angeblich 250, aber das ist doch 200 bis 200.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber für mein Alter, Leute, ich werde dieses Jahr 42, ist so um 150, 160 rum echt gut.
Das sage ich jetzt einfach mal, so zum Selbstloben.
So, das machen wir mal kurz.
Human Benchmark.
Reaction Time.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie hier die, wie hier die, ähm.
Das könnte jetzt aber, ich meine
Das hat jetzt sehr viele Sachen, die hier fehlschlagen können
Oder anders reinspielen können
Das sind andere Rechner
Sachen übers Netzwerk weitergeleitet
Capture Card und so
Das ist jetzt mal sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen
Probieren wir mal aus
Naja, Leute
Guckt mal, 20 Millisekunden
Unterschied, ganz ehrlich
Niemand von uns
merkt wirklich
so extrem beim
Arbeiten auf dem Desktop
und im Terminal
hier 18, 19,
20 Millisekunden Unterschied.
Ja, da sind wir uns ja einig,
dass das Auge sieht ja eh nur
12 FPS pro Auge.
Mit zwei Augen 24
und 48, wenn man das so
im Kopf stellt.
Nee, nee, 12, nicht 10, 12.
Das habe ich mal wissenschaftlich
belegt, dass das so ist.
Ich finde es geil, dass man damit teilweise
Leute auf Twitter und so immer noch triggern kann,
wenn man sowas schreibt.
Omega Lul.
Chat, irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, ich habe wieder komische.
Lass mal kurz was gucken.
Ne, das ist nicht mehr.
Ich hatte doch mal das Problem, dass hier manche...
manche Sachen hier irgendwie mit so einem komischen
roten und grünen Rand
waren, aber das ist nicht mehr so.
Das heißt, seitdem ich die Farbe umgestellt
habe in der Capture Card, ist das
okay. Können wir noch mal
kurz gucken.
Ja,
naja, alles okay.
Gut, exzellent.
Ja, wie gesagt, mit Sunshine brauchst du das mit Deskflow nicht, weil Sunshine ja auch Tastatur und so, Tastatur und Maus mit capturet.
Aber wie gesagt, bei mir war Sunshine nur so semi-gut geeignet.
Ich hatte da Probleme mit Copy-Paste und ich hatte Probleme mit Audio und sowas.
Das war nicht so geil.
Ich würde gerne ein kleines, privates, nicht kommerzielles Web-Tool hosten.
Ist Hetzner dafür das Beste oder wo hostet man am besten die kleine Sammlung von DB-Backend?
Hetzner ist nicht verkehrt.
Nachdem alle gerade ein bisschen die Preise anziehen, ich finde, bei Hetzner kann man nicht viel verkehrt machen.
Ja, wenn du jetzt irgendwelche besonderen Hochverfügbarkeitsansprüche hast,
dann, wobei ich sagen muss, ich hatte persönlich bei Hetzner auch noch nie einen Ausfall.
und letztendlich
die Hetzner Cloud Kisten sind ja auch
irgendwelche VMs, also wahrscheinlich
sind das irgendwelche Cluster
da drüber, die dann im Zweifelsfall dich auch umziehen
oder so, vielleicht, also wenn die
Hardware ausfällt, wirst du ein bisschen Downtime haben, denke ich mal
aber
insgesamt hatte ich da wenig
Probleme, wie gesagt, ist aber keine
super teure
Enterprise Hardware oder so
drunter aber preis leistungsmäßig schlägt das nix gibt aber noch ein paar andere haus da die
somit ähnlichen preis region spielen aber ich persönlich habe eigentlich die letzten jahre
über fast ausschließlich hetzner benutzt mal ganz kurz für ich weiß gar nicht mehr was genau
digital ocean landes irgendwas habe ich mein digital ocean gebastelt gibt es aber schon nicht
mehr und auch ganz vereinzelt mal kleinkram bei cloud flair wobei immer nur das fried hier als geht
ja und auf der arbeit ist es eigentlich ausschließlich sagen wir 90 prozent google
und 10% Azure.
Also 90% GCP, 10% Azure.
Azure.
Ist OVH noch ein Ding? Ja, ja, die gibt's auch.
Wobei OVH, da
wollte ich mir... Oh, und da steht eine Sache.
Chat, eine Sache habe ich noch. Die habe ich ganz vergessen.
Ähm,
wartet mal.
Ja, eine Sache habe ich noch vergessen.
Ich habe bei
Ionos, glaube ich.
Ionos habe ich auch noch
eine VM.
Die habe ich aber gar nicht mehr
in Betrieb. Die behalte ich
aber da, weil
ich habe mir mal da einen Lifetime
1 Euro Server
gekauft vor, keine Ahnung,
8 Jahren oder so.
Und er hat eine Public IPv4
Adresse.
Also 1 Euro im Monat.
Also Lifetime 1 Euro
im Monat.
Und
die hat eine Public IPv4 Adresse.
Allein schon dafür
lohnt sich es, diese Kiste zu behalten.
Ja und OVH wollte ich mal benutzen, war aber nicht möglich, weil ich bei OVH mich angemeldet
habe, habe mir einen Server gemietet und auf einmal habe ich eine Mail von denen gekriegt,
ja bitte scannen Sie uns Ihren Ausweis ein und schicken uns den.
Da habe ich gesagt, ne, ne, mache ich nicht.
Ist das neu?
Weiß ich nicht, ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her
Also, das machen die schon eine Weile, wenn das immer noch so ist
Ja, und dann hab ich auch noch
Eine Lifetime-Kiste, aber die haben mich
Beschissen
Ich war mal bei einem Anbieter, ich sag jetzt explizit
Dabei war, und empfehle ich
Auch nicht, der hieß irgendwie was
In Richtung
Cloud at cost hießen die
glaube ich ja also man sieht schon ein äußerst hoch geschätzter anbieter sehr
hoch geschätzte anbieter 15 rezessionen ein stern
Ich glaube, den Anbieter gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Genau.
Ich hatte nämlich auch...
...dort mir einen Lifetime-Server gekauft.
Der hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mal 31 Dollar oder sowas gekostet.
und habe ich mir gedacht für 31 dollar lifetime server macht es einfach mal genau hier one price
per live und anscheinend sie aber mittlerweile bleibt sondern irgendwann und irgendwann haben
die dann gesagt irgendwie ja wir sind die züge business talk ja wir freuen uns sie darüber
informieren zu dürfen ihre lifetime subscription ist das beste und eine
lifetime subscription bleibt bei uns auch immer lifetime
deswegen sind wir sehr erfreut ihnen mitteilen zu dürfen wenn sie ihre
lifetime vm weiter lifetime mäßig verwenden sollen müssen sie ab jetzt
irgendwie einmal im quartal eine maintenance fee bezahlen
das haben die halt gemacht weil das halt ansonsten sagen müssen dass die
lifetime vor allem nicht mehr lifetime ist ja aber sie gesagt einfach eine
maintenance fieber und dann dann habe ich auch gesagt ja ich will sehr nicht
für den preis bei diesem schrott ding dann könnt ihr mich weil ich bezahle
keine maintenance viel
Was ist denn Wind Scribe?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Lul.
Ja, da können die lange bitten, oder?
Aber die haben das bestimmt auch schön verkauft.
So nach dem Motto, wir freuen uns,
ihnen stets den höchsten Service bieten zu dürfen.
Und sowas.
Das ist ja dieses Business Talk, kannst du gleich komplett in die Tonne kloppen.
Tja, aber ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, selbst schuld, oder?
Wer seine Rechnung nicht bezahlt, wird irgendwann gebannt.
Und Hetzner weist sich da auch fünfmal oder so drauf hin.
Erst werden die Kisten abgeschaltet und dann kriegst du...
Also ganz ehrlich, irgendwann muss man halt auch mal seine Rechnung bezahlen.
Ja, 3 Cent ist irgendwie lächerlich, aber ja, ab wo sollen sie anfangen?
3 Cent, 30 Cent, 3 Euro?
Teamspeak, ja.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass Teamspeak enorm abartig zu hosten ist?
Man würde eigentlich davon ausgehen, Teamspeak ist so eine Anwendungsstelle.
startest du so eine TeamSpeak-Exe,
nee, nicht Exe, TeamSpeak-Bin, dann geht das.
Aber TeamSpeak ist von der Lizenzierung und allem drum und dran wirklich so eklig zu hosten,
hat keiner richtig Bock drauf. Und man darf auch sehen, mittlerweile ist es ja auch gar nicht mehr so
verbreitet. Wobei viele, die auf Qualität und
Latency Wert legen, tatsächlich immer noch auf TeamSpeak sind.
Ach, die haben gesagt, wir haben nie angegeben, wessen Lifetime wir meinen.
Oh Gott, das ist natürlich auch harter Scam, wenn die schon so argumentieren.
Ja, klar.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das gibt es jetzt auch noch, ja.
Hat sich aber nie so großartig durchgesetzt.
Wambel.
Hust, Hustworts.
Was soll ich gucken?
Irgendwas sollte ich mir doch einmal anschauen hier.
Das da, oder?
da reg ich mich aber auf wenn ich das jetzt angucke rad schnellweg fm1
ok gucken wir mal gucken wir mal und ich reg mich ich reg mich auf über bürokratische sachen und und
generell muss man ja sagen gerade hier rad infrastruktur ist schon hart grenzwertig
hier teilweise.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, keiner
interessiert sich für TeamSpeak 5 und 6.
Die miebeln das ja
selbst auf Twitter schon.
Du meintest letztens mal, ja,
Moment, ich switche mal hier rüber.
Caterino finde ich irgendwie viel nicer
zum Lesen mittlerweile. Du meintest
letztes Mal, ja,
dass du zwei NVMe-SSDs
als Raid 1 hast. Ja.
Welche du dann in der Nacht
auf eine HDD runterschreibst. Ja, so ungefähr.
Runterschreibst.
Kann ich mir die HDD als Backup vorstellen
und die SSDs von dir als eine Art Cache
unterm Tag? Oder hast du die NVMe
so groß, dass du dort auch alles...
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Haltst du die nur als Cache von Österreich in der Nacht
alles runter von... Ja, ja, so wie du schreibst.
Also, mein Plan... Also,
es ist noch nicht hundertprozentig klar,
wie ich es machen werde.
Aktuell.
Oder scheiß drauf, wie es aktuell ist.
Also,
was ich vorhabe ist,
auf dieses SSD RAID 1,
da kommt alles drauf.
Meine VMs, meine
LXC Container
und alle möglichen Sachen, die ich so
24-7 laufen habe.
So, mein Doc Ploy
mit den ganzen Services drin, mein Home Assistant
und so Zeug. Das ist alles auf der SSD drauf.
24-7. Es wird da auch nicht runter
gemovt oder so. Das wird nur
einmal nachts quasi, ich sag mal,
ganz stumpf geersynct.
Auf eine
Platte, die sonst halt ausgeschaltet ist.
So ist das,
so ist der Plan.
Vielleicht auch auf die Platte, die wir
dann im nächsten
Stream schucken aus dem
externen Gehäuse.
So, was ich jetzt mit dem Caching,
was du meinst was wir das letzte mal gemacht haben ist folgendes ich habe in
umv mergerfs installiert mergerfs ist ein overlay nämlich overlay union union
filesystem das heißt du kannst zwei ordner nehmen
die können auf unterschiedlichen laufwerken liegen und bekommst einen
Union View da drauf, also sprich
wenn Datei A in Ordner
A liegt und Datei B in Ordner B
liegt, hast du dann in deinem
MergerFS View
A und B im gleichen Ordner liegen.
Sieht aber nur so aus,
unter der Haube sind die schon auf unterschiedlichen Platten.
Und jetzt kann man folgendes machen,
wenn in diesen
Union
Mount Point, diesen MergerFS
Mount Point, wenn da Dateien
geschrieben werden,
kannst du sagen,
legt die Datei immer erst auf Part A an.
So, Part A könnte dann zum Beispiel die SSD sein.
Das heißt, alle Sachen, die da reingeschrieben werden,
die landen erstmal auf der SSD
und dann habe ich nachts, soweit ist der Plan,
dann habe ich nachts ein kleines Skript,
was die Sachen von der SSD auf die HDD verschiebt.
Aber nachdem ja sowohl SSD als auch HDD
zusammen gemerged sind in diesem einen View,
erkennt man gar nicht, worauf es liegt, ob auf SSD oder auf HDD.
Es sieht einfach so aus, als ist es immer da.
Aber ich kann saumäßig schnell reinschreiben,
weil neue Dateien immer erstmal auf der SSD landen
und dann nachts einmal weggemoved werden auf die HDD.
Und weggemoved heißt auch, die SSD hat wieder Platz.
So weit in der Theorie.
Wie gesagt, wir haben das im letzten Stream ausprobiert,
das funktioniert prinzipiell auch,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich das jetzt schon Monate am Laufen
und wüsste, das ist best ever.
Ja, und so werde ich das dann wahrscheinlich machen.
Einzige Sache, wo es failen kann, ist,
wenn du Dateien transferierst,
die größer sind als dein SSD-Write-Cache.
Also mein SSD-Write-Cache, sagen wir mal,
hat noch 700 GB oder so frei
und ich kopiere jetzt eine 1 TB Datei,
das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, sie muss schon im Stück auf die SSD passen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wie oft kopiert man Dateien, die größer als ein Terabyte sind?
Das kommt da äußerst selten vor.
Und dann kannst du MergerFS, ist im MergerFS glaube ich immer noch einstellen, Dateien, die größer sind, sollen da erstellt werden und sowas.
Max, ich muss morgen 8 Stunden Bahn fahren
Ohne Verspätung
Boah, wie Glück
Das wird grausam
Max hat es dringend
Eine sehr gute Idee
Mach ich jetzt
Chat
Ich muss mir schnell noch was zu trinken holen
dass meine Erkältung
schon da weg geht, ich hol mir nochmal einen Tee unten
bin gleich wieder da, ihr könnt euch eine Runde
in der Zwischenzeit eine Runde
Aski-Quarium angucken
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, wieder da.
Wasserkocher ist an.
Muss ich also gleich holen.
Boah, chat, das ist echt der Wahnsinn, ne?
Wenn man erkältet ist.
ich bin jetzt bisschen außer atem vor einfach nur treppen hoch laufen fast
schon wie früher wo ich noch 25 kilo fetter war
da gucken wir uns mal das video an ohne und ich versuche ohne um mich nicht
aufzuregen
34 km Radschnellweg zwischen Perfektion und Matsch.
Tja, das hier sieht richtig gut aus.
Wisst ihr, es gibt ja viele Autofahrer.
Habe ich mich früher übrigens auch immer drüber aufgeregt.
Viele Autofahrer regen sich drüber auf, wenn sie Fahrradfahrer auf der Straße sehen,
obwohl direkt ein Fahrradweg daneben ist.
Habe ich früher auch gemacht.
Chat, wer von euch macht das noch?
Es gibt bestimmt viele, die das machen.
der massiv der Arsch wehtut.
Fahrradbill gehören auch einfach so auf.
Ja, die Infrastruktur ist teilweise echt treulich.
Was ich halt auch immer affig finde, ist, wenn du Leute hast, die auf der Straße dann auch noch nebeneinander fahren und sowas.
Das muss nicht sein.
Das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Was ich auch immer doof finde, sind, was ich auch nicht mache, sind Leute, die quasi rechts vorbeifahren an der Schranke und sich dann vor alle stellen und sowas.
Finde ich auch blöd.
Ich bleibe einfach an der Stelle stehen, wo ich halt jetzt bin.
Ich überhole da keinen mehr an der Schranke oder so.
Ja, aber die Fahrradwege sind schon oftmals echt beschissen.
Ist das laut genug?
Das geht echt lauter. Warum ist das so leise?
Oder ist mein Chat, oder ist mein Ohr einfach verstopft?
mit Lichtbreite und Komfort und dann endet's.
Und du stehst im Matsch, schiebst durch Drängelgitter
und bist wieder im ganz normalen Radnetz-Abenteuerland.
Ich bin Marvin, Verkehrsplaner im Studio.
Und heute geht's um den Radschnellweg FRM1 von Darmstadt nach Frankfurt.
Denn bei Stadt, Land, Rad schauen wir uns an, wo Radverkehr richtig gut funktioniert
und wo er sich eher so anfühlt wie, wir haben's versucht.
Ich bin die Strecke komplett gefahren, von Darmstadt Hauptbahnhof nach Frankfurt zur Hauptwache.
Da würde ich nicht im Fahrrad durch wollen.
Wenn sie offiziell noch nicht komplett fertig gebaut ist.
Dazu gibt es unterwegs meine Kommentare, ein paar Fakten zum Radschnellweg und am Ende die große Frage.
Wie nah sind wir an einer echten durchgehenden Pendlerroute?
Wahrscheinlich sind wir da noch eine ganze Ecke von weg.
Was ist der FRM 1 überhaupt?
Der FRM 1 ist Hessens Vorzeigeprojekt.
Vorzeigeprojekt. Ein Radschnellverbindung...
Ist doch geil, wenn das schon das Vorzeigeprojekt
ist, ne? Wenn schon das Vorzeigeprojekt
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig funktioniert.
Die China-Chinesen hätten wahrscheinlich in der
Zeit, wo der Fahrradweg gebaut wird,
schon fünf Flughäfen gebaut oder
so. Gut, ich mein, dort
werden wahrscheinlich dann auch 20 Arbeiter
jeweils im Fundament eingegossen worden
und es hätte keinen interessiert, aber du musst es ja
mal nicht übertreiben. So ein Zwischending
wäre vielleicht nicht schlecht, oder?
Jetzt nicht 15 Jahre Machbarkeitsstudie,
und dann die seltene Wildgrille,
die nistet und deswegen nichts gebaut werden kann.
Aber vielleicht auch nicht
20 Leute im Fundament eingießen.
Irgendwas dazwischen, was halbwegs schnell geht,
aber sicher ist. Das wäre doch schon mal ganz nice.
Zwischen Frankfurt und Darmstadt.
Offiziell ist die geplante Länge
mit 25 Kilometer angegeben.
Egelsbach.
Egal.
Ja, so, ich habe gerade meinen Tee gebracht bekommen.
Egelzbach ist auch so ein Charakteraufwaller.
Je nachdem, wie man die innerstädtischen Zubringer mitzählt, wirkt es in der Praxis natürlich auch länger.
Die Idee dahinter...
wo ich arbeite in der Innenstadt. Das sind auch so ungefähr 34 Kilometer einfach.
... möglichst nah an der Bahnstrecke Frankfurt nach Darmstadt, damit du flexibel kombinieren kannst.
Also Rad, S-Bahn und dann wieder aufs Rad.
Und jetzt kommt der spannende Punkt.
Stand Ende 2024 ist der südliche Abschnitt zwischen Langen und Darmstadt Nord durchgehend fertig.
Circa 11 Kilometer sind es bereits.
An Spitzentagen fahren da schon über 2000 Radfahrende pro Tag.
Genau in der Größenordnung, die vorher prognostiziert wurde.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen zu laut.
Und diese Route hat ein paar echte Details, die es so gerne auf Mehrradwegen geben könnte.
Aber Chad, wann wird dann geflamed?
Ich will wissen, wo geflamed wird.
Weil wenn das jetzt einfach alles gut ist, dann freue ich mich und dann muss das Video halt nicht gucken.
Hier.
Wo es bergab geht, okay.
Wir skippen mal bis zu der Stelle, wo es schlecht wird.
... Provisorien, weil das Umfeld perspektivisch nochmal umgebaut werden soll.
Dann...
Ja, das ist schon wieder eklig.
Geht's Richtung...
Ich meine, immerhin ist das hier ein bisschen...
Warte mal, das...
Das geht aber noch.
Das geht ja noch.
Das ist immerhin eine komplett eigene Spur.
Spur kann man jetzt nicht dazu sagen.
Und dort endet für mich...
Sogar ein bisschen abgetrennt und so, das ist schon okay.
...die durchgehende Radschnellwegqualität.
Bevor wir in den Außerortsteil kommen,
gibt es hier noch eine sehr ungewöhnliche Fahrbahneinengung.
Was? Da muss man rüber?
Radschnellweg auf unter 2 Meter Breite.
Und jetzt kommt der Teil, der ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen...
Okay, das ist jetzt Vorstufe vom Fellenweg.
Weil er zeigt, warum Stückwerk so frustrierend ist.
Du warst gerade noch auf der hochwertigen Trasse
und plötzlich bist du wieder im normalen Wegenetz.
Erst sind wir noch auf...
Und jetzt bist du hier durch den Matsch?
Ja, das ist ja für den Arsch.
Moment, hat er nicht gesagt, der Weg ist fertig?
unterwegs, aber dann
kommen auch die Waldwege.
Ja, vor allem für das
Problem bei sowas ist,
du kannst sowas
mit einem normalen Straßenrad, also
mit so einem Straßen,
was allgemein so unter
Rennrad gilt, ja,
kannst du sowas schon fahren, aber
schön ist das nicht.
Das ist auch nicht mal
asphaltiert, das ist so Kies oder sowas
drauf.
also mit einem Straßenrad kannst du,
das geht schon, ja,
aber, aber,
Olli ist was anderes.
Und im Februar mit Forstwegen?
Vor allem habt ihr da, guckt euch mal
die Einschläge da an, die es da gibt,
die Schlaglöcher und sowas.
Ist bei uns hier auf Waldwegen
auch oft so, da musst du echt ganz
genau gucken, wenn du da durchheizt.
...Dinger grauenvoll.
Ja.
Matschpiste, grobe Steine, eine Rüttelplatte.
Überlegt euch mal, wie eklig das ist,
wenn es wirklich mal frisch geregnet hat.
Also auch richtig viel, ja.
Das hier sieht so aus, als ist es schon seit ein, zwei Tagen
halt trocken und halt immer noch matschig.
Ja, also das ist natürlich für so einen speziellen Radschnellweg
irgendwie ziemlich kacke.
äh, ich würde sagen, das ist so ein Zwischending
zwischen festgetretener Erde
und ein bisschen so Kies oder sowas
aber das ist so ein typischer
Waldweg, wie das bei uns ist
es gibt, ganz ehrlich, Leute
ich mag diese Waldwege überhaupt
nicht, ja, da liegen auch so viele Steine drüber
wo ich da immer denke, ey, wenn das mal der falsche
Stein ist, dann hast du gleich den Reifen
platt und sowas und ich
hab ja schon, ich hab ja nicht die Rennradreifen
Ich habe ja schon ein bisschen dickere drauf.
Glaube ich.
Was habe ich drauf?
44?
44? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Gibt es 44? Moment, wir gucken einfach mal.
Muss mal... Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, was für Reifen ich genau drauf habe.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ich habe...
Ich habe gar nichts anscheinend.
Genau.
Ich mag auch Feldwege.
Ich mag diese Waldwege, die man da im Video sieht.
So richtige Feldwege,
wo einfach nur feste Erde ist.
Gerade bei schönem Wetter.
Die fahre ich mit dem Gravelbike mega gern.
Aber diese Kies-Splitt-Waldwege,
die mag ich gar nicht.
So, also.
Reifen.
Reifen, Ausstattung,
Laufräder,
nee,
äh,
Reifen. 44,
nicht, äh, 40, nicht 44.
40.
Hab ich. Also, die sind schon
deutlich robuster,
haben ein bisschen Profil,
und, ähm, sind auch
ein bisschen breiter, also kannst du ein bisschen weniger Luftdruck reinmachen,
als jetzt irgendwelche Straßen,
reine Straßenreifen.
Damit kann man solche Wege noch fahren, aber wirklich mit einem reinen Straßenfahrrad sind diese Wege echt nicht toll.
Und dann kommt noch ein Drängelgitter.
The fuck? Was ist das?
Und ich sag's ganz klar.
Das ist ja mal komplett für den Arsch.
Wenn ich mein Fahrrad dann nicht normal durchfahren kann, dann ist das keine zeitgemäße Radhauptroute.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Das ist ein Hindernis.
Vor allem, dass es immer regelmäßig dann auch Straßenkost und so, Straßenkost, das ist alles suboptimal.
In Dreierhech-Buchschlag geht es dann durch Nebenstraßen.
Hier gibt es viele Villen, viel Grün, insgesamt ist dieses Viertel wohl sehr wohlhabend.
Und danach geht es wieder in den Wald Richtung Neu-Isenburg.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde
das sieht nicht aus wie so ein primärer
Radschnellweg oder sowas
Für mich sieht das aus
wie ganz normale Waldwege, die ich auch hier
regelmäßig fahre
Überlegt euch mal, diese
Radwege sollten ja auch dafür sein
dass du morgens und abends
auf die Arbeit fahren kannst und zurück
Mach das mal
Fahr mal so ein Ding, ich meine du musst eh
was anderes anziehen, wenn du sowas fährst,
ja, mach das mal.
Fahr das mal, du bist
sowas, also wenn das nass ist, du bist
sowas von dreckig und dein Fahrrad
ist dreckig und fahr das mal
vielleicht beispielsweise auch ein bisschen später und sowas,
ja, brauchst du eine echt gute Lampe,
mit auch ein bisschen Akkuleistung,
ähm,
aber du bist sowas von dreckig danach,
ja.
Also
das sollte, es ist,
Also das doch quasi als Fahrradstraße oder so oder Fahrradautobahn oder wie auch immer, das passt da hinten und vorne nicht.
So grob, dass es dich wirklich durchschüttelt.
In dieser Jahreszeit liegen wirklich überall Baumstämme entlang der Waldwege.
Entlang der schnurgeraden Wege bewegen wir uns nun Richtung Neu-Isenburg.
Ich mag solche Wege auch nicht.
So Wege, die durch den Wald gehen und kilometerweise einfach nur geradeaus gehen.
Das mag ich nicht. Ich mag schon den Untergrund nicht.
Und irgendwie, da ist auch so nix.
Da kommst du dir immer so vor, als kommst du überhaupt nicht voran.
Am Ortseingang unterqueren wir nun eine Umgehungsstraße.
Für uns geht es erstmal weiter auf dem Schutzstreifen der Kurt-Schumacher-Straße.
Alles noch kein Radschnellwegstandard
Das sind ganz normale Straßen hier
Habt ihr es übrigens hier
Das ist auch immer geil
Hier ist ein Radweg
Da fragt man sich immer wo der weiter geht
Weiter auf dem Schutzstreifen der Kurzschuhmacherstraße
Guck hier ist noch sowas
Soll sowas ähnliches sein wie ein Radweg
Und jetzt
Jetzt ist er einfach fertig
Gut man könnte jetzt sagen
Ja klar man muss hier halt über die Gas fahren oder so
aber das ist einfach weg.
Und danach fängt er wieder an.
Nee, danach fängt er nicht an.
Danach kommt erstmal Bushaltestelle und sowas.
Was ich auch toll finde,
hier bei uns, in der Nähe,
gibt es Maps Frankfurt.
Eine der Stellen, wo ich echt
immer richtig ungern
langfahre,
Rodenbach
Irgendwo in der Nähe von Hanau.
Ja, genau.
So, da geht hier eine Straße durch.
Hanauer Landstraße.
Jetzt machen wir hier mal Street View.
Ja, da fährt man dann hier rein.
So.
Also, hier, das da, das hier ist ein ganz brauchbarer Radweg.
Ja, also hier mit Asphalt und so, den kann man wirklich fahren.
Die ganze Strecke hier lang.
So, aber sobald du hier ins Ort reinkommst, hört der extra Radweg erstmal auf.
Und es gibt auch für beide Seiten nur den hier.
Ist klar, ist zu klein.
Aber dann wird das zu einem Rad-Fußgängerweg, der zwischendurch auch noch...
Bin ich da schon vorbei?
Hier, der zwischendurch auch noch Bushaltestellen hat.
Also das ist wirklich mega für den Arsch.
Da stehen dann hier die Leute rum, hier fährt dann noch, hier halten dann teilweise noch random irgendwelche Autos, wir hoffen, dass gerade kein Bus kommt.
Da fahre ich so ungern lang.
Und hier haben sie mal wieder gedacht, ach komm, können wir mal ein bisschen rot machen.
Und ein weiteres Problem, was man da hat, ist, dass man an den, das ist wahrscheinlich bezeichnend für ganz viele solcher Wege in Deutschland,
dass man an diesen Einfahrten
teilweise
die Dinger
die sind teilweise
das hier geht noch, die sind teilweise
nicht richtig abgesenkt
das heißt, du musst da wirklich
du musst da hier drüber fahren, ne
und dann musst du hier bremsen und ganz langsam
hier hochfahren, dass dir nix irgendwie
in Reifen rein
beißt, so
schon ganz schön für n Arsch
Ja guck mal, seht ihr wie hoch das ist?
Seht ihr wie hoch das ist?
Fahr da mal hier drüber mit 20 Sachen oder so.
Mach das mal.
GLHF.
Nach Neu-Isenburg geht's wieder in Richtung Frankfurt.
Wir unterqueren die A3 und danach sind wir offiziell in Frankfurt am Main.
Übrigens, solche Unterführungen hier, gibt es bei uns in der Ecke auch einige,
die sind teilweise komplett überschwemmt, wenn es mal viel geregnet hat.
Da steht dann gefühlt ein halber Meter hoch das Wasser drin manchmal in solchen Unterführungen.
Komplett für den Arsch, kannst du überhaupt nicht fahren.
Wir sind offiziell in Frankfurt am Main.
Warum ist der nördliche Abschnitt eigentlich noch nicht fertig?
Und jetzt kommt wieder die logische Frage.
Warum endet der gute Standard eigentlich in Langen?
Und warum ist der Abschnitt Richtung Dreieich, Neu-Isenburg und Frankfurt noch nicht durchgehend?
Offiziell ist es ziemlich klar benannt.
Die Abschnitte Langen-Nord, Dreieich, Neu-Isenburg und Frankfurt sind noch in der Planung.
Ey, und allein schon, wenn ich das hier so sehe, guck mal, was du hier hin und her machen musst. Vor allem, das sind solche Dinger. Meint jemand wirklich ernsthaft, das hier, das hier, wo auch Fußgänger und allem am Start sind, das hier wäre eine, vor allem, was ist denn das für ein Untergrund hier?
Meint wirklich jemand, das hier wäre eine gute Idee
für so eine Fahrrad, ich nenne es mal eine Fahrradautobahn?
Stell dir mal vor,
hier fahren im Sommer wirklich viele Leute dran.
An der Ecke dauert es doch keinen Tag,
da gibt es irgendeinen Unfall.
Zum Glück wahrscheinlich nicht so schlimm,
weil die Leute nicht so schnell sind auf beiden Seiten.
Hast du mittlerweile CacheOS im Dualboot installiert
oder ist das wieder eine VM?
Weder noch.
Das ist CacheOS.
Da ist doch der Spiegel, der reißt da voll raus.
Das ist ein Mini-PC
mit AMD Ryzen.
Richtiger HS ist der Ryzen.
Wo steht es hier?
Ja, 7840 HS.
Mini-PC.
Aber ich habe es trotzdem auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Per Capture Card.
Der zweite Desktop.
Das Output wird gecaptured vom Mini-PC.
... in der Planung. Und mit dem Bau einzelner nördlicher Abschnitte soll 2026 begonnen werden. Stand März...
Ja, soll begonnen werden. Es ist ja schon Anfang 2026. Da wird jetzt erstmal die 50. Machbarkeitsstudie durchgeführt.
25. Das ist genau der typische Zeitfresser-Mix.
Trassenvarianten, Abstimmung über mehrere Kommunen und Richtung...
Guck mal, das macht doch ernsthaft.
Das macht doch absolut keinen Bock, hier mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren, oder?
Das ist eine stinknormale Straße.
Was hat das mit Fahrrad, mit Schnellweg zu tun?
Das ist eine ganz normale...
Das ist eine ganz normale Straße, mit wahrscheinlich sogar morgens relativ viel Betrieb.
Abstimmung über mehrere Kommunen und Richtung Frankfurt werden die Randbedingungen komplexer.
Und Frankfurt selbst hat da nochmal eigene Großstadtrealitäten.
Ja.
Die Stadt teilt die Strecke in Stadtwald und Stadtraum.
Und hat Vorplanungen beschlossen.
Alter.
Ich hatte einen Zug, so eine halbe Notbremse hingelegt, ein bisschen weiter weg.
Weitere Planungsaufträge im Volumen von 2 Millionen Euro bewilligt.
Der Beschluss dazu aus dem Juni 2025.
Dazu kommt ein ganz konkreter Bremsklotz.
Der Abschnitt im Ziegelhüttenweg soll zwischen Oktober 2025...
Ah, da weiß ich, wo das ist, der Ziegelhüttenweg.
... und März 2028 von der Deutschen Bahn als Baustellenanbindung für die Forsthausbrückenerneuerung genutzt werden.
Und die Herstellung der Radfahrer...
Wärst du manchmal mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit? Ich würde gerne, ich habe aber keinen Bock auf Frankfurt Innenstadt, auch wenn es nicht viel ist.
Hier geht die Brücke rüber, ne?
Vom Südbahnhof
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo der Süd...
Ist das hier direkt am Südbahnhof?
Es muss aber hier irgendwo...
Hier irgendwo muss...
Ja, hier ist doch Südbahnhof, ja klar
Oder ist hier der Süd...
Ne, der Südbahnhof, der ist...
Man läuft ja quasi vom Südbahnhof
Hier so mehr oder weniger dann hoch
Wie lange wäre das?
Circa mit dem Rad?
eineinhalb Stunden.
Ungefähr einfach.
So ungefähr.
Ja.
So ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden, würde ich sagen.
Es sind 34 Kilometer,
aber du kannst ja da nicht
und Anfang bis Ende durchheizen.
Radschnellverbindung ist dort erst ressourcenschonend
nach der DB-Bauphase vorgesehen.
Und das ist genau dieser Moment, wo du merkst,
Radschnellwege sind nicht nur Asphalt.
Das ist auch viel mit Koordination, Baustellenlogistik,
Zuständigkeiten, der Finanzierung.
Und ja, dafür brauchen wir insgesamt einfach Geduld.
Nee, ganz ehrlich, ich hätte auf sowas absolut auch keinen Bock, mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren.
Ankommen im Stadtraum und wieder Mischverkehr.
Und dann Frankfurt Süd. Wir fahren unter den Bahngreisen durch.
Jetzt sind wir am Südbahnhof, ne?
Und obwohl du hier eigentlich merkst, okay, das ist doch jetzt der Anschluss.
Ach, hier sind wir.
Wirst du erstmal wieder auf die Straße.
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, wo wir sind.
Doch, doch, ich weiß, wo wir sind.
Hier ist es doch jetzt...
Hier neben, hier rechts, oder?
Hier rechts ist der Ausgang vom Südbahnhof.
Oder?
Nicht sicher.
...wieder auf die Straße geworfen.
Kreisverkehr neu gebaut und Radverkehr eher so Mischverkehr und gut.
Während wir durch den Stadtteil Frankfurt-Sachsenhausen fahren...
Hier hinten hat übrigens, irgendwo in der Ecke, muss glaube ich auch der Helter Steine seinen Laden haben.
Sieht man deutlich die Herausforderungen gründerzeitlicher Stadtquartiere.
Boah, ey Leute, guckt euch mal das an.
Das hat doch jetzt wirklich nichts mit Fahrrad-Schnellweg zu tun.
Es ist ganz normales Rumgezuckeln mit dem Fahrrad durch die Frankfurter Innenstadt.
Immer mit dem Gefahr, dass irgendein Depp nicht guckt, nicht umfährt.
Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Mit dem Umgefahrenwerden.
...hoher Parkdruck und viele...
Boah, ey, guckt euch das mal an, wie beschissen das ist.
Und dann völlig plötzlich eine richtig schöne Protected Bike Lane.
Tja, aber die hört wahrscheinlich ja gleich wieder auf.
Frankfurt kann das, aber es ist eben nicht überall.
Dann überqueren wir den Main über die alte Brücke.
Und ich will mich auf Nebenstraßen einsortieren.
Nur, in der Innenstadt sind viele fahrradfreundliche Nebenstraßen in der Praxis oft Zubringer zu Parkhäusern.
Mit vielen parkenden Autos.
Boah, ey.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich nicht mit dem Fahrrad morgens auf die Arbeit fahren will.
Wegen genau sowas.
Das sind zwar nur die letzten vier Kilometer oder so, aber das sind die größten Abfahrkilometer überhaupt.
Wenig Platz.
Zu viel Slalom.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Und genau hier endet meine Fahrt.
Hauptwache.
Zeil.
Die Hochhäuser im Blick. Und ich denke mir, wenn der FRM 1 irgendwann durchgängig fertig ist...
Ja, wie soll der überhaupt durchgängig fertig werden?
Weil ich meine, die können ja nicht das jetzt in Frankfurt großartig anders machen.
Also doch, doch, ich nehme das zurück, das könnten sie schon.
Aber da besteht glaube ich keinerlei Wille dazu.
eine richtig starke Pendlerachse.
Aber solange die Lücken noch
Matsch, Strängelgitter und Mischverkehr sind,
bleibt es eine Route für Leute, die es
wirklich wollen. Das Fazit.
Ach, hier sind wir jetzt.
Ja, auf der Zeil.
Hauptwache.
Hauptwache ist, glaube ich, hier unten. Da geht's runter.
Hier ist
auch der Weihnachtsmarkt.
Was die RM1 schon richtig gut macht
und was noch fehlt.
Mein Fazit in drei Punkten.
Ja, guck, hier geht's runter zur Hauptwache.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Guck mal, hier irgendwie hoch ist die Goethestraße.
Erstens, der ausgebaute südliche Abschnitt zeigt, wie gut das funktionieren kann.
Breite, Beleuchtung, direkte Führung und diese Alltagsdetails wie Haltestützen und Schrägwurfmülleimer.
2. Den Schrägwurfmüll. Das ist ja was Nices. Ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Die Nutzung ist da. Das ist keine sinnlose Asphaltfläche.
Über 2000 Radfahrende am Tag. In der Prognosengrößenordnung.
Und an Spitzentagen wird das auch schon erreicht.
Und das, obwohl der Weg noch nicht mal zur Hälfte fertig ist.
3. Die größten Probleme sind die Brüche.
Knotenpunkte, Mischverkehrabschnitte, Barrieren und die fehlende Durchgängigkeit Richtung Frankfurt.
Und ja, Planung und Finanzierung laufen weiter.
Frankfurt hat Beschlüsse durchgeführt, Planungsgelder zur Verfügung gestellt,
also der Bau soll in Teilen ab 2026 starten.
Aber es gibt auch harte Abhängigkeiten wie DB-Baustellen bis 2028 im Stadtraum.
Jetzt interessiert mich eure Meinung.
Was muss ein Radschnellweg für euch erfüllen,
damit ihr wirklich sagt, okay.
Ganz ehrlich, so was wie hier durchgehend wäre super.
Und wo man halt nicht extra irgendwie was Neues bauen kann,
dann halt so, dass du eine eigene Spur,
einen eigenen Weg wirklich für die Fahrradfahrer hast.
Dass du nicht permanent da irgendwie drumherum dingsen musst
und dir irgendeiner einen Weg reinfährt.
Das ist alles von der Arsch.
oder das Ausweichen muss doch
gar auf dem Fußgängerweg.
Ja, aber so sieht's aus.
Wahrscheinlich wird das Ding nie fertig werden.
Bei uns dauern ja
Bauvorhaben immer Jahrzehnte.
Was macht eigentlich Stuttgart 21, wo wir gerade
beim Thema sind?
Moment, sollte Stuttgart 21 nicht eigentlich
letztes Jahr schon eingeweiht werden?
Sekunde.
Was macht denn das eigentlich?
Dauert noch länger.
Stuttgart 21 im freien Fall.
Wisst ihr übrigens,
wisst ihr, wofür 21 steht?
Nicht nachgucken.
Das steht für das 21. Jahrhundert.
Das 21. Jahrhundert ist schon zu einem Viertel vorbei.
Und das Ding ist immer noch nicht da.
Ja, ja, letztendlich ist es
die Bahn plant das Ding
und dementsprechend
ist die Bahn dafür auch verantwortlich.
Dieses ganze Fingerpointing da immer
...
Kann durchaus sein, dass ich die Strecke sogar früher...
Ach nee, Ulmen, nicht Ulm.
Weil ich bin öfters an Stuttgart früher vorbeigefahren. Mannheim, Stuttgart, Ulm.
Aber es gibt Führungen für die Baustellen.
Geil.
Haha.
Also ich weiß, dass sich der Weg früher nach Ulm immer enorm gezogen hat.
Da musste man irgendwie so einen Berg oder sowas hoch.
Und das war immer super lahm.
Und die Busfahrer waren extrem unfreundlich in Ulm.
Da kann ich mich noch früher dran erinnern.
Der Rest war Ulm aber echt okay.
auch wenn ich da jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt hin müsste.
Aber an sich ging es klar.
Die Anzeige ist raus, hoffe ich mal.
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Vielleicht geht es mir morgen so weit gut,
dass wir auch...
Mir geht es tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen besser auch schon.
Den ganzen Tag im Bett liegen ist auch nicht gut.
Vielleicht geht es mir morgen so weit gut,
dass wir aufwachen stream machen können kann nichts versprechen und eventuell wenn wir morgen
kein aufwachen stream machen können geht es mir vielleicht mittags besser dass wir dann die fest
platt schuppen können weil wir zeit dass die festplatte geschockt wird die die die liegt
hier schon neben mir und sag hier Schuck, Schuck.
Schuck mich.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass es
eine CMR-Platte und keine
SMR-Platte ist.
Ich weiß, dass das keine Secret of Mana
Musik ist. Aber ich finde, die Musik
hat irgendwie einen Secret of Mana Touch.
komplett ukraine das stream noch zum vergleich zudem zu dem n5 ja aber
wobei ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher bin wie ich das am besten mache weil das 4800 pro das
wollte ich ja eigentlich wieder zurück schicken das heißt wäre besser wenn ich das gar nicht
auspacke und das 4800 plus kriegt der max also serious max aber das können wir uns noch mal
zusammen angucken es ist so gut wie kein unterschied zwischen dem 4800 plus und im
4800 pro oder wie das heißt einzige ist irgendwie ein performance core mehr der
rest ist genau das gleiche das gucken wir uns auf jeden fall an noch mal bevor ich das los schicke
weil es ja auch kein schlechtes nass als finde rein von der hardware ist das ist das mini forum
schon eine ganze ecke besser weiß ich ähnliche kategorie aber mini forum ist ja bisschen dafür
bekannt geräte nicht wirklich gut zu supporten also die bringen geräte raus gibt dann die bios
updates und nächstes jahr gibt es ein weiteres und so was also ja vielleicht ist es bei ukraine
besser kannst du das eine überhaupt noch zurück schicken das 4800 pro kann ich
noch zurück schicken da sind jetzt erst glaube ich 20 tage
oder so das schicke ich nächste woche schicke ich nächste woche zurück das
4800 plus das kann ich nicht mehr zurück schicken
das macht aber auch nichts gucken uns im stream zusammen an und dann schicke ich
der max
ja chat so sieht's aus schön dass ihr dabei war ich gehe das essen auch für
morgen ist wieder besser.
Dann werden Festplatten geschuckt
und Aufwachen-Stream gemacht. Hoffe ich, ne?
Wie gesagt. Also wundert euch nicht, wenn ich morgen früh
nicht da bin. Je nachdem, wie es mit Nase
laufen so ist. Bis dann.
Macht's gut. See you.